you
I certainly first have to say that I
consider myself to be secular I
certainly don't think burkas are
something that I'm comfortable with when
I see women in them with their faces
almost entirely covered it's it's a sort
of hard in a culture which is a open
culture in which faces are uncovered
it's very hard to to deal with on the
other hand it seems to me that you can't
separate the French desire to ban this
from a kind of underlying racism about
Arabs and Muslims former Colonials from
North Africa and West Africa and you
there's just no way to separate them and
so on the grounds of the fact that this
constitutes a form of discrimination and
a failure to actually consult with the
the people who are wearing them and to
find out what indeed is involved in the
the the where the choice on the part of
some women the the influence of others
on them to wear these these things it
seems to me really inadvisable as as a
as a law and can will only be taken by
minority populations as yet another
strike against them and if anything it
will increase the numbers of people who
are wearing these rather than do away
with them so as a policy issue in
countries in which Muslims are a
minority population in general and in
France in particular I think it's a
really bad idea to ban these things I
think that certainly wearing a headscarf
is a different thing from wearing a
burka actually but in either case there
is a certain there is at least in part
the notion that you have to cover women
to prevent the sort of sexual temptation
of men that they represent but there are
other it seems to me Muslims are not
alone in this Orthodox Jews women have
to cover their heads and wear long
sleeves and you know there's all kinds
of dress
for Orthodox Jewish women that also
indicate their inferiority but I think
no one would dare talk about
post-holocaust no one would dare talk
about or would have it a very difficult
time trying to ban certain of the
behaviors of Orthodox Jews would be
considered a legitimate interference in
religious practice Catholics your
Catholic nuns certainly still have to
cover their heads I mean there's there's
all sorts of religious practices in
which the inequality of women and men
are manifest in behavior and clothing
and the rest of it it seems to me a
terrible mistake to single out Muslims
at a time of clash of civilizations in
countries in which there's a tremendous
amount of class and other kinds of
economic and political discrimination
against them it doesn't seem to me to be
wise policy at all